[Musique]
aujourd'hui aussi événements dans touche
pas à mon poste
et oui c'est sa première avec nous on
est très heureux d'accueillir catherine
la banque est avec moi la classe
l'élégance voilà catherine est ce que
vous avez quelques mois dire à nos
téléspectateurs
je vous écoute ta vidéo
je voulais vous dire que je suis
enchanté d'être là et je remercie
beaucoup cyril d'avoir fait ce d'avoir
essayé osé avec moi parce que
franchement autour de la météo
d'habitude les films demande de ne pas
oser mais c'est vrai qu'avec vous catry
j'ai osé et je suis très heureux que je
dirais j'espère que vous allez beaucoup
vous amuser avec nous et en tout cas on
va tout faire pour parce qu'on vous aime
très fort merci à catherine laborde et
file au japon catherine va faire son
premier jeu avec nous catherine est ce
que vous aviez vous donne envie de
zapper ou de maths et va au début j'ai
cru que je voulais mater mais après
l'avoir vu je crois que ça pète été
suffisant
[Rires]
les marqueurs
attention pour catherine je remet au
goût du jour la tecktonik talent merci
catherine laborde et sa première au dos
lui merci mac à petit
c'est comme un petit nom dans le dans le
privé katika tout cas tout ou plutôt
quatre patrons bien séchage aime les
chats je sais exactement vrai moi ces
dogues
voilà sinon ces deux buts étant tous les
noms pour être chiens et chats canada
merci allez on y va